-You guys, I read about
a new COVID variant
that has some people worried.
It's called XBB.1.5.
I guess they couldn't think of
a catchier name.
And it actually inspired me
to write a tiny song.
Roots?
♪♪
-♪ There was Alpha, then Delta ♪
♪ Then Omicron next ♪
♪ But this latest variant
might be the best ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ Another brand of COVID-19
has arrived ♪
♪ It's a new strain ♪
♪ But it isn't the same ♪
♪ Sounds more like
Elon Musk's kid's name ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ Not UB40,
who sings "Red Red Wine" ♪
♪ Put on your mask when
you're inside a facility ♪
♪ It could be a robot from
a "Star Wars" trilogy ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ Not OMG or MP3 or TCBY ♪
♪ Or an eye chart made by
a really high guy ♪
♪ Sounds like the password of
your parents' Wi-Fi ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ XBB.1.5 ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]